let me go to the money question besides
how you got this junket the money
question is will the new leadership be
able to speak directly to Germany yeah I
mean I think that look they say they're
going to Aaron Alexis tsipras talked
about how he was going to go to Germany
and not wear a tie when he met a Angela
Merkel he's heavy on symbolizing
symbolism and I think you know you look
at the choice of coalition partners
today he's partnering with the
independent Greeks a right-wing party
whose only common ground is that they
are opposed to the bailout so he's
insisting that you know he is tying
himself to this anti-bailout line and
you know it's gonna be a fascinating
negotiation Joe I look at the defeat of
the establishment personified by mr.
Papandreou from years ago is the
establishment defeated and / or can they
be like Richard Nixon and come back in
two three four years look I think it's
pretty amazing how far the establishment
in Greece has been wiped out I mean you
look like pashto used to be like the
dominant party in Greece and now it's
nothing look you can it always come back
new democracy is still a pretty
significant party but just the collapse
of establishment the establishment in
Greece and really across Europe that's a
big story establishment parties
everywhere are seeing their popularity
fades and yeah and Joe to that point I
heard last night people shouting at the
rally Tsaritsa podemos making the
connection between what's going on in
Spain and the anti-austerity movement
there and what is happening with the
rise of Tsaritsa in Greece does this
victory sort of light a match against
aunt for anti-austerity parties across
the continent yeah I think that's really
the huge story right now in Europe the
fact that there is this sort of
pan-european leftist movement I mean
podemos is the head of podemos Iglesias
came and campaigned with tsipras I saw
lots of signs that had series on podemos
together so yeah this is like the big
story and I think obviously a lot of
people on the European left are hoping
that Greece is just the beginning of a
bigger story